So here's a mapping app
that I've already created.
This one is identical to all the others
that you've been using throughout this
course.
It has a single view and
there's a map fragment on that view.
The Gradle file is set up for
the play-services libraries.
And the manifest file is set up
in the usual way with OpenGL,
with the services libraries, with the
API key, and with the permissions that I
want to use, internet access network
state and write external storage.
And of course on my
Google Developers Console,
as I showed you earlier on,
I've configured this API for
access through that API key and
the API key is here.
Now let's take a look
at the main activity.
So in my main activity class I've just
created a number of local variables
of marker options type and I just named
them after the various rinks, renton,
kirkland, everett, lynnwood,
montlake, kent and showare.
I've also created a camera
position that I called Seattle,
which is just the default
camera position that I'm using
when the application actually launches.
Then, in my uncreate function,
I called the marker options in the way
that I had demonstrated on the slide.
So, for example, Renton is new
marker options with the latitude and
longitude of Renton and
the title Renton.
I was able to get the latitudes and
longitudes for each of the rinks
using the technique that I showed
earlier on just using Google Maps,
dropping a pin and reading
the latitude and longitude from them.
So I've set up all of my marker
options for all of my rinks.
And then in my onMapReady function, so
remember the onMapReady callback
gets called when the map is ready,
because I've implemented onMapReady
callback in my activity.
So when the onMapReady gets called,
I simply add all the markers to my maps
so, m map dot add marker Renton and
map dot add marker Kirkland, etcetera.
I add them all and
then I call fly to Seattle.
And the flyTo function is very similar
to the one you saw in the previous
demo except this time I'm just moving
the camera, I'm not animating it.
So then I'm just going to
fly to Seattle and
I'm just going to jump
into that location.
I haven't put any flyTo
to the particular rinks.
The only time flyTo has been
called in this application
is right at the beginning,
when I say flyTo(SEATTLE).
And the only time that the flyTo
function's called is, of course,
in the on mapReady
when I flyTo(SEATTLE).
So that would just give me a default
view, looking at Seattle in
the location where we could see
all of the rinks on the same map.
So, I had moved the camera to
the appropriate location to allow me to
do that, and that was the camera
that was defined as Seattle.
As you can see here,
with the latitude/longitude, zoom of 10,
bearing of 0, so I'm looking straight
down, and a tilt of 45 degrees.
That was pretty simple, right?
And in the next step here, you're
actually going to build a custom marker,
so you're not going to use
the default marker pen.
You can create your own marker,
for example, a hockey player.
But before we get to that, let's have a
little quiz about using markers on maps.